We're going to pivot to the panel,
uh,
on,
whether computers can be racist.
And we had a great,
great group,
uh,
for you.
Uh,
you all know Bradley Horowitz,
uh,
who is,
obviously,
uh,
[inaudible] at Google.
Uh,
he's,
uh,
running the new,
he can tell you about it,
but the,
the new,
uh,
area,
the new entrepreneurial,
uh,
incubation hub at Google,
and he is passionate about all of these,
uh,
these issues.
And,
uh,
and,
what we can do with tech,
uh,
Nancy do [inaudible] is user experience,
research program man,
a manager at Google,
and she leads a research on the experience for all new launches.
So as she puts it,
she gets to see,
you know,
all the problems with all the products.
Uh,
so she's,
uh,
well,
well suited to talk about these,
these issues.
Megan Rose Dickey,
uh,
is also here.
She's a reporter who's a,
you're probably familiar restroom,
worked at tech crunch,
focusing on diversity inclusion and social justice.
She was at business insider,
uh,
before that.
Uh,
we also have a Neil dot dash who's a quite a thinker on a lot of,
uh,
tech issues,
especially in terms of how tech can be more humane,
a,
an inclusive,
he's an entrepreneur.
He's a technologist.
I believe he's recently become a CEO of a software company as well.
Uh,
so great group.
Van's going to lead this.
I will exit stage,
right?
Uh,
so how about you sir?
Alright,
David Drummond
at the bad brother.
If you don't worry about this stuff all the time,
it's just because you don't have to,
but the residents think about all the time.
You know,
there's the famous thing with,
I'm a professor would let Latanya Mcsweeney,
and she's a professor.
She typed her name in and then what comes back or these ads around,
you know,
getting somebody who's criminal records and all this criminal stuff.
And she does the research and it turns out that people who were offering these
services were,
had picked up a bunch of African American names and had the ad search trigger.
Downside is if you're looking for a job and somebody googles you dizzy,
if you're a good employee,
boom,
here's this suggestion that you might be a criminal and so
that would suck.
So,
um,
what can be done to prevent it?
So we've,
we've got some examples of how bad it is.
What can be done to prevent this?
Maybe,
you know,
more inclusive hiring.
But from your point of view,
you think about this stuff a lot.
How do you think about it?
Um,
this particular situation,
uh,
with a,
Tanya
had actually some difficulty to do with the ad d designers who were purchasing
names of African Americans,
which means that we need to be very about our guidelines,
right?
We need to start to find a way to capture these use cases and create content
around that.
And the other thing is we need to be able to test those in the right
environments.
Um,
I,
this makes me think of Tay,
the chatbox.
Do you guys know about the artificial intelligence chat bots on Twitter from
Microsoft that became racist and 16 hours and sexist to 16 hours?
Um,
what's interesting about Tay as tay was tested for two years in China where free
speech is not necessarily something that's readily available.
You can,
you can't just say whatever you want,
right?
But when it was introduced in America,
even though they were testing for bias at the time,
within 16 hours,
like Bradley said,
because it didn't have the right environment or the right people to test it on
this occurred.
So how can we make sure that we have not only the right use cases available,
but we also are testing in populations that might be affected.
Are we amplifying the voice of the underrepresented right?
Are we testing and communities of just women we testing in different
socioeconomic backgrounds?
Um,
so one of the things I'd been pressuring,
at least from a research standpoint,
is making sure that from the very beginning,
our research criteria is mixed as far as gender,
socio economic background,
race even left handedness,
right?
To make sure that we're creating inclusive products for,
for better reach in the world and versatility in this world.
Uh,
Neil,
I want to get you in here.
First of all,
I love that purple.
Uh,
uh,
it's a tribute to somebody.
We both laughed.
We both look,
this is the first time I've been in public,
not wearing purple since,
uh,
April 21st.
So,
um,
I,
uh,
that's a whole other topic.
Um,
best practices though.
So,
so we,
I think we got a good problem statement.
Good overview.
Uh,
we got,
uh,
a personal testimonial to the need for what?
For wokeness.
Um,
we got a few ideas in terms of how we can begin to improve.
But,
uh,
Neil,
I'd love to hear more from you on the same basic vein.
Well,
I look at this now,
you know,
I'm CEO of a company that makes software,
right?
And so we have to take this head on.
And the first thing I look at is,
um,
educating ourselves about the issue,
right?
So as an industry,
what tech companies,
little or big have done is the strategy of pretending we're neutral,
right?
And this has been a very smart thing to do from a regulatory standpoint,
So if we say we're just a neutral platform,
we just reflect society.
Don't regulate us.
Please.
Right?
That's been this tactic that's gone over and over and over.
And I look at that for like out in the world,
something like Uber where,
um,
part of what they've done to present themselves as saying,
we're in neutral platform where anybody can hail a cab and,
and there are good things,
right?
So I,
I mean,
I can't even count how many black friends I've said.
It was like,
okay,
I can hail a cab now because I got to a,
and that's great.
And I said,
well,
yeah,
but for operating outside the world of regulation,
when they start red lining your neighborhood,
what are we going to do to rein them in?
And we don't have an answer there.
And what they've done is very effectively used the tactic of presenting
themselves as neutral or benevolent to avoid the,
you know,
the regulatory infrastructure and social infrastructure that we use.
And we don't have that history,
right?
So if you want to do a startup today,
you come from a CS background and that's great.
I mean you should have those technical skills and that's powerful and valuable,
but you probably had little or no ethics training or when you came up through
that cs program,
you probably had little or no social justice training and we came up through
that program.
So there's no history where you can learn about,
well how did,
how did you know red,
red lining and zoning and all these other exclusionary patterns manifest in the
past that I don't duplicate them in my software.
And how did you know the labor movement to duplicate in the past?
And so bringing that learning into,
when you say red lining,
yeah.
Can you just break down what that means in a practical way for people who live
in this world is all we worry about,
but yeah,
but red lining means the,
the shortest version is using policy and particularly in the case of geography,
like neighborhoods and communities to entrench and enforce a discriminatory
practice around race,
religion,
and other systems of exclusion.
Okay.
How's that look?
Red Light in means
if you live in this neighborhood,
you ain't get no loans.
If you can't get alone,
you can't do much.
You have the best little company invests a little business.
Best little idea.
If you can't access capital,
you're stuck.
And this practice is so pervasive that there's a term for it called red lining
that everybody knows and understands.
And the concern now is that rather than the technology companies actually get
it,
getting us to a place where you can equally get access to stuff based on your
ideas and not based on your skin color,
your zip code,
that is actually coming back again.
Again,
we blew up the death star and now here we are back again.
Rebuild game guys with,
with the red light sabers.
And that's it.
So we don't have that history.
We don't know that piece.
We don't teach that in a,
there's no intro to coding program that teaches you this is what red lining is,
right?
And this is why the,
you know,
the highway was built through your part of town and not somebody else's part of
town.
Right?
Right.
And so until we know that,
how are we going to say,
well,
I know how to fire up x code in eclipse and I can make an APP.
And that means that I understand the impacts of red lining and what
transportation and transit policy are.
Those are two totally different things in those people,
but don't talk,
and I think this is,
I want to come back to you now.
I'm ready.
I think that there is this weird thing for people in tech.
You didn't set out to be a social engineer.
You didn't set out to be the government.
He didn't set out in your mind,
it must be,
isn't this someone else's job to be doing?
I'm just trying to make these gadgets Gizmo,
right?
I mean,
I'm not a tech person,
but that's,
that's the right term that I see.
I,
I studied in the car.
So,
and yet it turns out that you guys go from these little geeky people that nobody
pay attention to.
No offense
kind of being like the digital lords of the universe and the digital age.
So you suddenly,
if he can't now say,
well Geez,
you know,
I don't want to have to go to the diversity class,
leave me alone.
I mean,
doesn't success then with great power doesn't come great responsibility.
I'm just asking.
So,
um,
I think one thing that I've found,
this concept of woke,
like I think a lot of people at Google,
we've got 65,000 employees who in my experience are pretty well intentioned yes.
And believe that they are doing good for the world and our sort of techno
optimists and all that.
And I think what we're coming to grips with is that as we're repeating here at
the panel,
uh,
good intentions are not the end of the conversation.
They are the start of a journey.
And one thing that I've really been making use of is there are people who've
spent lifetimes thinking about this,
studying it in a scholarly way,
working on these issues,
picking them apart,
understanding them.
And it's not like in an hour training,
we're going to sort of get up to speed on,
you know,
a system of oppression that's been hundreds of years in the making.
We have to turn to these experts and we have to invite them into the
conversation and we have to not sort of think we got this,
but rather,
you know,
come humbly to the,
to the knowledge that's out there already.
Yeah.
Woke to me.
You started us off.
Um,
are there things that you're seeing now they give you either great encouragement
as far as,
I mean that I thought that comment.
I mean,
that was as good as you can get,
at least from my an intention point of view or the things that give you
encouragement that you're seeing developing.
Are there things that give you great frustration?
Um,
yeah,
it's a,
it's a combination.
There's definitely a little bit of both going on.
So in,
in the last couple of years or so,
there's been a lot of talk around unconscious bias trainings and you know,
increasing the number of underrepresented minorities and women and Lgbtq I a
people in these tech companies.
But,
um,
unfortunately it seems like we're kind of getting to this point where there's
not,
we've kind of hit a wall in a way and there's still the problem of actual
inclusion and these companies and,
um,
like I just,
I wonder,
I mean,
I think an event like this is totally great to,
you know,
get employees at these big tech companies talking and thinking about race and
injustice in the tech industry.
Um,
I just want to see a quick show of hands,
um,
who,
let's see.
What was this mandatory where you are you guys here by choice?
Okay.
So that's cool.
We are here.
Oh,
because we
want to be more diverse
now that it's about me.
It's all about you.
But I mean,
I,
I struggle,
I go back and forth with the idea of mandates.
But I do think that something like this,
if it were mandatory for all employees to attend that could be,
that could be helpful.
I mean this is what,
maybe an hour of your time and,
but let me ask you though,
so these people are all here because they want to be in there.
People who are watching all around the country who wanted to be,
you have a chance to talk to people who might actually be able to make a
difference.
I'm like what is the barrier now?
I mean before there was,
there was almost no conversation about it.
It's like I remember like the digital divide back in the nineties like,
well is every kid going to get a computer?
And now kids have computers in their back pockets,
um,
of some kind.
But then a couple of years ago there was a much bigger conversation at least
talking about the need for more inclusion,
more diversity.
Um,
and you,
you feel some lag between the conversations in the outcomes.
What is in the way,
what are some of the things that you see that may be not obvious during the way?
Well,
micro aggressions are huge and that's unfortunately not always visible to
people.
It's very visible to the person experiencing that microaggression,
but not too much to the outsider.
It might be very easily dismissed.
Um,
but I think in general,
just being,
being an advocate for,
for diverse people at your company and you know,
listening to them and hearing them out and then thinking like,
okay,
like that's interesting.
Like how can I,
how can I help make sure that this person feels more supported and actually
wants to stay
okay.
But I'm not going to let you go with that.
Okay,
good.
That's nice.
Um,
but
you basically were saying,
just be a good person.
Just be a good person.
Don't be racist,
don't be sad.
But I'm saying that I think most people see themselves as good people and
they're trying,
but something gets in the way.
What,
what's,
what's stopping it?
So one of the things I think I talk a lot about designing for empathy and I
think that you can do that with your own life as well.
I really believe that privilege can actually disadvantage to privileged.
And so it takes stepping out of your comfort zone and experiencing other things.
And,
and actually,
you know,
I talk about discomfort and a lot of people aren't comfortable being
uncomfortable,
but for example,
I'm uncomfortable every single day,
right?
Every single day.
And so it's one of those things where to take a moment of your day out to maybe
go into an inner city and tried to help Mike give you an experience and a
perspective that might impact your work differently.
Right?
Or
You said designing for empathy,
right?
So go ahead.
Oh,
what,
what I mean by that is like I'm in my own work,
I always am trying to figure out a way to necessarily sympathize with people,
but empathize,
really understanding what their needs are.
So I'm designing ethical and social logically
impactful solutions for them,
right?
Not just trying to get it done,
you know?
And I think,
um,
in some ways we think about it externally,
but we can also do it within our own lives.
So I'm going to bring a New Zealand,
where I like about what you're saying is that it builds on the earlier points,
which is first of all that there are people who know a lot of stuff.
Like if we're,
if you're to try to solve a problem,
you can,
you know,
take the intro course,
you can read a book or you can also deal with the experts.
So you're saying they're experts.
You need to be dealt with.
You're saying also you need to just continue to just want to be good to your,
to your coworkers and you're saying there's a way you can even change your life
where you're bringing in those and,
but you know,
Dave and I were talking about that before.
Like,
you know,
Oakland's not that far from here.
Um,
but I,
I just think that there must be some,
there must be some things that are not obvious that are stopping that from
happening.
If everything you guys are saying just seems perfectly reasonable,
but I guarantee you in four hours people are going to be doing something.
Not that.
So,
so why?
But we're talking about making our products more empathetic and more ethical.
You know,
a lot of what we're talking about is we need more black and Latino creators.
For them.
I'd say the single biggest barrier to more black and Latino creators in tech is
Asian American men.
And want to be clear here.
If you look at our potential for advancement,
CEO,
Google and CEO of Microsoft,
CEO of Dolby,
[inaudible],
CEO of my company,
we are Asian American men,
right?
How many,
how many Asian American men are here but trans up.
Okay.
As a percentage.
How does that compare to the percentage of Asian American men at Google?
Right.
And we don't know our history,
right?
Asian Americans in general don't know we are here because we were welcomed by
black and Latino neighborhoods and communities.
And then we turned our back on them.
You know?
And then there's a history of anti-blackness.
We don't know that history.
Now granted,
some of that's because people are new.
They haven't been in this country that long.
They haven't learned about the civil rights movement,
not excusing it.
But I think there's a way to just say there's learning to do and what happens is
if you look at proportional representation is compared to the population of
California versus population,
a tech companies,
percentage of white employees is roughly proportional to overall population
representation of black and Latino workers is extremely low and most of the gap
is taken up by Asian American workers,
primarily Asian American men.
We are able to advance.
There are issues now,
there are,
you know h one B issues,
there's immigration issues,
there's a lot of disparities.
But the biggest thing we have is we take up a lot of space and we don't give a
lot of voice to the people.
We need to hold the door open.
[inaudible] and one of the things I'm
mindful of is white folks can't say that.
Cause there'll be afraid to say that.
And I,
and I would encourage you,
if you're white,
don't say it,
it's not your place.
But,
but that means that we have to be doubly loud.
If you are an Asian,
you know,
person in tech to talk about this issue of we take up a lot of space and we
don't fight real hard.
Um,
and we build systems that exclude and we don't interrogate them.
So,
you know,
I think that's a thing that,
how many of you have heard an Asian American man and say this issue,
talk about anti-blackness in our community.
Like there's three hands,
four and you follow me on Twitter doesn't count.
Um,
the,
that's the,
that's,
I mean,
I think that is one of the most key issues here.
And we,
we don't have a vocabulary for it and we don't even have a way to have that
conversation without it being mediated by essentially white media.
Right.
And it's like we don't have that dialogue between various Asian American
communities and Black and Latino communities to address.
Well,
first of all,
I,
uh,
I'm rarely speechless,
so I'm right.
But we have seven more minutes.
Um,
you know,
this question around solidarity,
mm.
Uh,
is very interesting.
Um,
one of the great achievements within the African American community over the
past 15 to 20 years has been,
you know,
frankly,
because of leaders like,
uh,
Barack and Michelle Obama and others,
African Americans have moved
at least so far to a position of solidarity with the immigrant community.
I including with the Latino community
again,
because we don't talk about this stuff often in publicly business.
You went there,
uh,
in the 1990s here in California,
there was a big fight between black folk and Latinos,
the also on the east coast.
But I was out here for it and it was very bad and it was,
they are taking our jobs and what was happening was seeing more Latinos in the
service sector and in construction and African Americans felt like we were being
displaced
and it was ugly.
And African Americans,
leaders of Barack Obama's,
um,
caliber stepped in and said,
we're not going to do this.
We're not going to be used and trekked to
essentially create Jim crow and Brown face for this whole population of people
who are here and they're working hard,
et cetera.
And yet it was tough in the black community for awhile.
Also,
the question around LGBT
Lgbtq,
I,
Yay,
that was a tough question.
And the black community in the 1990s especially because so much of our struggle
comes out of the church and it was a,
it was an issue and we have gotten to a point in the black community where solid
there obviously you have a leg gay folk as well,
so it's not like a strictly like a racial issue.
But this question around are,
you know,
heterosexual,
cisgendered,
black folk going to be in with our own folk and other,
and that was a big fight.
You're now at a place in the black community where I'm a preacher,
my preach against that issue,
that preacher will not march,
that preacher will not go and actively attack.
So when black folks talk about this heartbreak around a lack of solidarity,
it's not out of no context.
It's out of saying,
here we are,
a community law.
I'm a ninth generation American,
ninth generation American.
I'm the first person in my family that was born with all my rights,
recognized by this government.
In nine generations.
I was born in 1968 my cousin Kenny was born in 64 before they signed the last
civil rights bill.
So I'm the first person in Nigeria.
The of with all my rights in our community and the native American community
continues to be the lowest in every area.
And yet on a moral question,
do we stand with the Latinos when people want to deport them on a moral
question?
Do we think marriage should be for everybody?
Uh,
you look at our voting behavior,
we are the most progressive on those issues.
And so it's all dirty.
Should be a two way street.
Yeah.
And,
and I think that that's a part of the heartbreak for our community to be seen in
such a negative light.
Often you're the criminals.
You're the scary people,
you're the angry people,
you're the,
the threat.
But when you look at our performance and you look at the public role that we
play,
uh,
I think some of that stuff is not merited.
And so I,
I want us to find our way to solidarity.
And frankly,
I want to find our way to solidarity with the best of the Trump voters who felt
left out of this love circle because we have a lot of white men who are feeling
left out of this love circle and we can tell them,
you have,
well,
you know,
check your privilege or we can say,
check in with us and let's keep talking.
And so anyway,
I just,
I just want to say that,
uh,
this to me,
this,
this particular thing,
I've never anybody say that when you just said,
um,
and uh,
uh,
this is going to be an age in an era in the next four years at least where
solidarity is gonna be put to the test.
Um,
so that was not in my questions.
um,
so look,
I want to,
I just want to come back to you.
I mean,
here you are.
What a journey.
I mean,
you're one of the best in your field.
without question.
Uh,
you've done so much stuff that people use every day have heard of,
um,
uh,
you're a legend.
Keep going.
Um,
and then you stepped on a rake,
right?
Any southerners?
He stepped,
he stepped on a rake.
You ever stepped on a rake?
Okay.
And you didn't become
this bitter.
How dare they?
Well,
maybe you did it first,
but you at least do it right now.
You aren't showing up.
Is that guy who's like angry and bitter and defensive and how dare they,
and they're playing the race card and I'm sick of this.
You didn't become bitter.
You became better in a way that people rarely do on any side of these issues.
Why and how?
I think we should just close with that.
Um,
I think it gets down to humility sort of,
you know,
I think so many of us are good intention and I think your mandatory is a really
great question because we have those who have the most work to do,
may not know they have any work to do and they're in,
they're not the ones that are showing up.
And I would say I fell into that category.
I felt,
I,
you know,
I grew up in Detroit and lived in Oakland and I felt like most causes,
I was on the right side of,
and I didn't understand that the work started at home until I was humbled.
It took,
you know,
getting hit upside my head with the rake to sort of knock some sense into me or
to wake me up.
And,
um,
I think that's the way to approach this with humility.
It's not a problem that needs to be fixed.
It's not sort of,
you know,
we'll put a patch on the code and you know,
it won't be racist anymore.
It's a journey we're going to take.
And,
um,
we have to approach it with humility.
Um,
Google tends to like hard problems and once that may take 10 years or not,
you know,
things we shy away from.
So I think we're in this to win it and for the long haul.
And I feel that support from the company that this is something we're going to
do together.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm grateful to have an opportunity to be at Google in a company that cares as
much as I know we do.
Okay.
[inaudible]
well,
I see that we were counting down almost 20 seconds,
so I think that means we've got to go into the questions and the answers.
And so,
um,
uh,
just so you know,
you're going to get the last word cause we,
we started with you so everybody get a chance to answer,
but just get ready.
how do somebody telling me how we do the questions and answers in this,
in this joint?
We've got a couple of microphones acts up.
Okay,
good.
So we'll start with you on the paper.
Okay.
So folks can line up on the microphone.
Thank you.
Michael Skolnik by the way,
Kevin,
Michael Skolnik another random
great leaders.
You know,
often when we talk about humility,
I think,
especially guys here,
be weak.
I think guys here,
you know,
you're going to be a less than.
But when I think about some of the strongest people that I know or that I've
studied,
you know,
and Nelson Mandela certainly was not weak,
but there was that deep sense of humility that shines through.
And I think that we need some models where we can still be,
you know,
guys like to be guys.
I mean,
often not all guys,
but a lot of guys,
you know,
I'm talking about and there needs to be some opportunity for us to understand
that the call is for you to be greater.
We're not trying to pull anybody down.
We're not just calling people out.
We're calling people up to an even better,
uh,
expression of who we all can be together.
So look,
that said little sermonette over.
Um,
so I got two questions.
One says,
is our country currently in a dangerous situation where the term racism has
actually been abused?
And how can we determine a person is racist or just a victim of poisoning the
well,
for instance,
half the population voted for Trump this year.
Are they all racist?
Welcome back,
David.
By the way,
David Jones back.
Give him a round applause.
Um,
the jump ball question,
Mrs d,
Somebody asking a deep question is,
has the term racist had been,
you've been abused,
um,
calc you tell somebody who's actually a racist or just a victim of,
of of the circumstance.
Are All the Trump voters racist jump ball,
anybody?
Well,
this is that,
that structural issue,
which is like calling a person a racist isn't useful attacking systems of racism
is,
and so,
you know,
if you say to somebody,
are you a racist?
It's like,
yeah,
we're all participatory to different degrees and systems that are racist.
The question is whether you're rooting for their systems are dismantling them.
Right?
And so the,
the,
I think a lot of the rhetoric or like everybody gets called a racist,
I think that comes down to mostly white folks feeling defensive,
right?
And it's the like,
why do you use this term all the time?
So I'm like,
I actually have pulled back on like saying you're a racist just because it's
immediately he's going to put up the defensive wall and it's not useful.
And I never say,
you know,
if I say our criminal justice system is structurally racist,
do you support fixing that?
Uh,
you can have a meaningful conversation with people.
So I think some of this is just about the rhetoric now.
I can't expect everybody to take the time to learn.
Here's the perfect way to in a 140 characters to not make somebody defensive.
But if you have a platform,
I think that's a really important bit of work to do.
Can I chime in for a second?
Yeah.
So I think that's right.
And uh,
well one of the interesting things that I had noticed over this,
this campaign season was how a lot of the folks sort of inner around Trump and
sort of supporting him on TV and so forth.
If you started criticizing him on the basis of sort of racial issues and how
he's related to the black community,
Latino community,
the Muslim community,
uh,
they'd come back with your being racist.
Right?
So it's,
I think it's very important to be able to still engage with that.
So a lot of times,
you know,
you,
you sort of are deescalating and sort of,
you know,
it's like,
it feels like unilateral disarmament a little bit amongst know progressive folks
that say,
well,
I'm not going to call anybody racist.
I'm not going to call it out.
But yet other folks or are sort of using this very aggressive tactic of,
you know,
as soon as you make any criticism,
you're being divisive.
You're being a racist.
Yeah.
So
they think that you're never happened to me on television.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Other voices.
I was just gonna say that.
Yeah,
that happens to me a lot.
So a lot of what I cover is around diversity and inclusion.
And if ever I bring up,
you know,
issues of race or sexism or homophobia,
I'm,
I get called the racist.
I get called the sexist one.
I get called the homophobic one and it's,
I don't know.
But that's,
that's just the Internet for you.
And
I wonder,
is there,
is there something that we're,
that we could do better?
Yeah,
that's my question because,
yeah.
You know,
there's this,
there's this wonderful man named Jeffrey Lord who I got chance to spend a lot of
time with on television.
These actually is a wonderful person,
but on this issue we would just butt heads and um,
yeah,
he would say,
well,
you know,
the Democrats started the clan,
like what does that have to do with anything?
But
he just,
that was so important for him and we just couldn't figure it out.
So I just wonder,
and I wonder if I might,
you know,
risk your good standing that you've developed your being woke.
Yeah,
yeah.
Not Speaking for yourself,
but speaking for your old self and speaking for people who might be like your
old self and not to,
you know,
worship white fragility too much,
but
what's more effective and with less effective as we try to reach out on his
question?
It's not on my paper.
Just honest question.
Well,
I liked it.
You know,
I think labeling a is divisive and I think,
you know,
the minute somebody is back on their heels,
they're not listening.
Right?
So,
um,
I think confrontational approaches towards,
this rarely lead to the outcomes that we want.
Um,
and I think your advocacy for an approach of inclusion and love,
like,
you know,
empathy is a great word,
sort of appeal to people's humanness who amongst us hasn't been otherized in
some scenario,
no matter how much privilege you had,
you were the last person picked on the team or whatever.
It's a human experience to experience being ostracized and hurt and left out and
not included.
And,
um,
so I think,
you know,
giving people that benefit of the doubt and understanding that even when you
disagree,
you don't have to otherwise or you know,
turn people into enemies is both going to lead to more pleasant journey but also
lead to better outcomes.
So I think,
you know,
it's very hard to be grounded in that love and approach people you vehemently
disagree with who are looking to take away your rights and,
and still,
you know,
have the patience and determination and steadiness to sort of approach it that
way.
But I think history shown,
it's the only thing that works.
Yeah.
I'll say something about about that because it's,
um,
w what you're saying feels both unfair and true.
Hmm.
It's,
it feels unfair that the oppressed person has to be able to develop this
capacity to,
to help the oppressor do better.
And it also feels very true.
And I think that's part of the pain of being one down.
Like when you're one down,
you have all these sore spots.
When you're one up,
you have all these blind spots.
So the person who's one up on race,
or if you're white,
I mean,
I'm like,
I'm the most privileged person in the world has happened to be black,
but I'm,
but I'm one up on gender.
I'm one up on being heterosexual.
I'm one up on education.
I'm one up on knowing David Drum drumming.
I'm one of them.
A lot of things,
man,
except the boats.
But,
and so in those areas in which I'm went up,
I have a lot of blind spots and make a lot of mistakes,
but the area that I'm one down on race,
I have a lot of sore spots,
you know,
and it really hurts and I've had to figure out on national television in real
time how to be hurt and how to be real about it.
And at the same time,
how to try to keep the conversation here and how not to try to call people out
but try to call people up.
And I just,
what?
What I,
the only thing I ask is that when people who are one up ask that of people,
they,
they know what they're asking.
They're asking somebody to do something that I don't know if you can do,
you're asking somebody to do something that I don't know.
You know,
you shouldn't have to be Gandhi at work.
I mean,
you shouldn't have to be Dr. King just to go to work.
And yet I do feel that that's sometimes what's what's being asked.
But I love your response and I'll tell you what,
you guys have an incredible asset here in you because you've gone through the
journey and you know,
and I think that one danger is that we come out of hurt spots and sore spots.
So even when somebody has gone through the journey,
we're still almost ready to,
you know,
where's he going to,
when it was like,
and I do think that there should be some kind of catch all good badges or
something once people have gotten to a certain level of,
whoa.
So we can control so we can,
I think the convention is,
we give them cookies.
Cookies.
Yeah.
That's good.
You're welcome.
Michael is calling going.
Fire me if I get this next question.
Hold on.
I was like,
um,
how does it proliferate now?
This is deep.
How,
oh,
just go to the audience.
No more questions.
Okay.
Your new beautiful you and the blue.
Well,
thanks for coming.
Oh,
Van Jones really enjoyed your talk.
So my question is that it's been said that the only thing that's worse than
people talking about you is people not talking about you.
And for a whole year,
every day,
every week,
every hour,
CNN has been talking only about Donald Trump for better or for worse,
for whatever reason.
I,
I think for all the wrong reasons,
but still,
that's all that I ever heard.
Do you think that CNN,
the networks,
like it unwittingly contributed to Donald Trump's victory by giving it more
publicity than you really deserved?
Yes.
Next question.
Okay.
Thank you for coming.
It's been a great chat.
I wanted to ask the question.
I was hoping you would sort something out for me,
which is that the narrative seems to be now that the election was lost as a
result of economic insecurity by those folks in the belt,
Middle Midwest.
But what was Obamacare?
What was the auto bail out if it wasn't to benefit these people?
And we continue this narrative [inaudible] Bros with the election of Bush,
uh,
against Gore and Kerry.
This whole idea that the Democrats can't and,
uh,
don't speak well to these,
constituents.
And I,
I,
I want you to sort that out for me because it just doesn't seem accurate.
It seems like we're hiding.
Um,
if you look at the counties that were blue for Obama that went red for Trump,
there is a direct correlation with the most recent wave of factory closures for
which we did not.
We did that.
We didn't respond to you.
Now what I will say is simply this,
the fact that we then blame Hillary Clinton is bizarre.
Um,
the reality is a Republican's wouldn't support President Obama on anything.
Uh,
and they,
and they were rewarded for that.
Uh,
President Obama tried to do tax cuts for small businesses in the American jobs
act,
and the Republicans stopped him from giving tax cuts to,
to choose small businesses because they just didn't want him to be successful.
The president wanted to put forward infrastructure,
they called it socialism.
Now Trump wants to do what they call it patriotism.
It's the same bill.
It's lily the same approach.
So you are correct that it's messy.
It's a lot more complicated than it is,
but I think that it is also true if you go to those counties.
I went to the county because I don't do it.
Listen,
I love the media,
but you know,
I worked here.
I want to get my own taste of it.
It is in fact true that you had a large number of people who were willing to
vote for Obama and vote for him twice.
Who in this campaign didn't see themselves reflected and they didn't feel,
listen,
there are a bunch of people who were delighted by that stuff,
even secretly,
but I think a lot of those people were baked into the cake anyway.
It's where was the swing and my concern is that I don't want you to think that
the swing came from racial resentment.
The swing did not come from that.
The swing came from a diff connection with that candidate,
with the democratic narrative of inclusion that felt that didn't,
it didn't let them up with it.
They want it to be.
And the economic anxiety that is true,
which means that Trump is probably worse than you fear,
but Trump's voters are probably better than you fear.
And I want you to know that.
Right.
Hi.
Hi Mr. Jones.
My family was actually at the Muslim Public Affairs Council dinner yesterday
where you spoke,
so thank you for your presence there.
And also Megan,
good to see you.
She was my colleague.
Do
I?
Uh,
I wanted to actually talk,
I hear a lot about fighting for certain causes,
but I think the fight is often what causes the biggest divide.
How do we actually have those face to face conversations with people that we
probably don't either,
either know that that's their perspective or we don't meet these people.
I think a lot of times having conversations online can be very tough to actually
get anything through.
How do we have those conversations with empathy and really understand someone
else's perspective?
Well,
I recently saw some work,
uh,
that people are doing.
And I also saw some research from MIT around this that uses machine learning
when people are online and they type in a comment that may be bullying or
offensive sometimes inadvertently,
it puts a little pop up up there through machine learning and basically says
what you're about to post may actually be hurtful or inflammatory or derogatory.
Are you sure you want to proceed?
You know,
click yes if you want to,
if you're a troll,
you know.
Um,
but a lot of people actually,
when there's that moment of reflection when it's,
you know,
before they actually take the act,
if they just have that little angel on their shoulder,
you know,
um,
they actually back out and they rephrase it and they take it down a bit.
So I think there can be a role for technology to actually foster more useful
conversations.
And I think what we have right now is sort of,
you know,
a platform where anyone can say anything without consequences,
et cetera.
And so you're seeing a lot of,
you know,
the worst of ourselves out there.
But I think there's an opportunity to apply technology to improve that.
Let me just,
let me just double down on that comment.
I think we are working on that.
Yeah.
You know,
some of the folks at Jigsaw,
it used to be Google ideas are actually working on this very hard and it's,
it's pretty exciting because if you imagine the notion of sort of an empathy
engine,
uh,
you know,
using machine learning where,
literally it could be,
yeah,
we can use it to clean up some of the trolling,
you know,
that you see on sites and so forth.
Uh,
you can also use it as,
as Bradley says,
you know,
it's like maybe you get more context and more empathy when you're engaged in one
of these conversations and can adjust your message,
uh,
more productively.
So yeah,
there's a lot of stuff.
There's a lot of research being done on this data's Sida.
Yeah.
Dana boys research group out of New York.
They're doing a lot of smart thinking on this.
I think tech will be part of the answer.
The other part is at a personal level to the point of like how to,
how to be gone to at work.
Um,
you almost always have to leave with being vulnerable.
The only way you get somebody to deescalate when they're trying to like,
you know,
you're the real racist,
is to sort of go back to I'm a person and I'm trying to fight the same injustice
as you are.
That's hard.
Like you gotta be in the right place and they can't be like the phone ringing
and the baby's crying and all that other stuff going on.
But do you even find those people?
Like how do we get them?
They find me?
I don't know.
I don't,
I haven't had to go looking,
um,
after we got it as a few more more fucks with want to make sure.
Thank you for the question now.
That's great.
Cool.
One more comment and then we'll move.
Oh,
sure.
One of the things I was going to say is,
um,
I talk a lot to people about lending their own privileges to people who are
disadvantaged and that they can actually have a platform to feel comfortable
speaking where we fit.
Again,
lending your privilege if they more about that.
So that's the idea of,
for example,
if I come the Bradley and we're in a meeting and maybe I'm the only black female
there,
maybe he'll say,
you know what,
Nancy,
why don't you speak on this topic?
Or if I'd make a comment,
congratulate me,
you know?
Oh,
that was a great point.
A way of really highlighting someone who may be of a different background,
who may not have that voice to be comfortable to speak up and create an
environment where other people can speak with them too.
So,
um,
for people who are here,
who would like to get people to be a little bit more comfortable speaking to
them by providing that privilege to someone else,
that could also create the dialogue or a space to have an open dialogue to
really talk about some of these issues.
That's great.
Thank you.
Yes,
yes.
So actually my question happens to build off of that and Neil mentioned that a
lot of people coming out of computer science backgrounds don't have a lot of
ethics or social justice training,
but there are some of us here who do and a lot of the conversation around
diversity often revolves around hiring more.
But my question was what can we do with the diversity that we already have here?
Great.
I don't know.
Someone else has to answer
just as a user get louder.
I mean I think the biggest thing I'd love to see,
I would feel better about all the Google products I use all day,
every day.
If I saw more Googlers standing up and using their voices.
You know when Steve Bannon talks about undermining your CEO because he is of
south Asian descent,
like you know it's wrong,
you know,
you know that he's going for your leadership for no reason other than the color
of his skin.
That's wrong.
And you all know it and there's no,
I mean this is one of those rare cases were sucking up to the CEO of a publicly
traded company is the right thing to do for social justice.
Like let's celebrate it,
let's enjoy it.
That's great.
Um,
that's,
that's a rare treat,
right?
So I think,
and it like,
it will make your,
your bosses happy.
Why not do that?
I think those are the kinds of things where you can say something that might
seem obvious,
but the power of your voice is,
I think it's easy to underestimate when you're here.
Um,
you know,
this is,
this is one of those,
like if you have somebody who's never been in tech and never to silicon valley,
and they walk in the doors of this place,
when they write their Christmas letter at the end of the year to like what we
did this year,
they're gonna be like,
I went to Google.
Right?
That's one of the highlights of the year.
That's one of the most amazing things that happened.
And then you can do every day that's just going to work.
It's amazing to them.
And so a voice that comes from this place is still amazing and has impact and
you are,
you know,
the rest of the world thinks these are the smartest people in the world and they
have the most power in the world of almost named buddy.
And so every time any of you speak up,
it carries a weight that I don't,
I think it's easy to underestimate when you're all surrounded with each other.
It really,
really matters.
Good,
good.
So I think that's beautiful,
but may not scratch his itch.
Um,
David,
he's asking about
what more could be done.
It puts you in dog a position,
but what are the kinds of things that,
not necessarily even Google but companies can be doing
celebrity?
I think he was Austin talking about,
you know,
what,
what Google is going to do too.
And I,
you know,
I would just,
I guess my answer would be the internal version of what Anil just said.
Uh,
in that,
you know,
it shouldn't just be,
BGN black Google's was network,
you know,
who has a hoodie march on TJF to bring these issues to the fore.
Like more confrontation,
right,
of,
you know,
at,
at t gif of the,
of our leaders to make sure,
what are we holding it,
holding us to account.
Uh,
you know,
we,
the most important reason why,
you know,
we released the,
the,
our diversity numbers in my view at least,
maybe,
maybe others disagree,
was for us to be,
to subject ourselves to,
you know,
being brow beaten by people who think we're not doing enough.
Right?
Because that's super important from the outside,
but also,
but more importantly,
uh,
from folks at,
at,
at Google.
So,
uh,
you know,
I think it's another version of winning.
I'll set about making your voices more heard.
We should be hearing about this more,
more often at the OKR meetings.
You know,
we should be demanding that,
you know,
the Okr be up there that,
uh,
that we,
you know,
ask,
Sundar,
Larry and Sergei,
whoever else is up here,
you know,
what's our progress,
what progress have we made and,
and,
and whatnot.
The actions,
the other feature quite late,
sorry,
go ahead.
Sorry.
I just wanted to give a short response.
Um,
the other thing that you guys can do is possibly possibly bring somebody with
you when you come to these race at things.
Right.
I remember I went to um,
or I heard about Tim.
Wise talks gives me,
and he was talking about how we need to embrace our inner prejudice and racism
and the faster we embrace that,
the faster we'll be better.
And I thought to myself,
who would go to a Tim wise talk,
right?
Those are probably people who are pretty woke,
right,
so to speak.
But it would be great if each one of those people took one of their coworkers
and brought them into that top or brought them into this room.
There are plenty of empty seats here.
That's a little surprising to me,
you know?
And so what can we do 10 minutes?
We've seen it more power.
Yes.
So I mean I feel like we can do our part to make sure for all the future talks
on decoding racy.
We bring someone with us.
Beautiful.
You first I wanted to say thank you to the panel for opening up and sharing your
ideas.
I know it's kind of hard to maybe share your personal side.
I'm at work and Mr. Jones,
my husband who's the,
um,
he's a blogger on daily coasts.
He's a kid,
Oakland on daily coast.
He says hello.
Uh,
I'm also,
uh,
my question goes back to like what Nancy was saying,
where you mentioned something and then there's trolls online that Chen come back
and call you though the racist or the bigot or whatever.
What are some last words of infor inspiration for people who really want to
speak up but are maybe too afraid to say something in such a public forum?
So I guess I would say that you need to speak up anyway.
Like I don't think you guys know how hard it is for me to be present here,
right.
To talk about these things and constantly think about,
okay,
what might I say wrong that could potentially make me lose my job?
Right.
I think,
right.
I think it's,
if you understood just the amount of discomfort that it feels just to be a brown
person at Google,
for example,
that more of us would be just slightly more open to stepping a little bit more
forward,
if that makes any sense.
I wish somebody could really truly understand daily how it feels and I wish that
was enough encouragement to just say,
you know,
even a moment of you trying and asking,
I had a coworker asked me one day,
for example,
after a shooting,
did it get any better yet?
And My response was,
what?
Why would it be better?
And I remember he ran off after that and he was really scared,
but I was so appreciative.
I'm actually trying to have that conversation,
went back,
found him,
let's talk about this.
I'm not trying to scare you off,
but that is,
that was him trying to connect with me and trying to empathize with me.
And that gave me an opportunity to space,
to speak with them.
So be careful with the minority tax.
It doesn't mean harass your local black person.
Right?
Right.
It means so be conscious of that.
Just maybe ease in slightly and just say,
is there any way I can help or if you ever need a hug,
come get it.
You know,
little things you can do.
Yeah.
I just wanted to quickly chime in.
In terms of,
you know,
um,
okay.
So let's see.
I wrote an article like,
um,
back in last December,
it ended up getting on some like white supremacist reddit thread.
It got like hundreds of thousands of comments on tech crunch and it was a story
that I felt very proud about writing and I felt like it was something that
needed to be said.
It was,
you know,
of course about race and issues of diversity in tech.
Um,
and that was when I kind of had him like my first major dose of then people
firing back and calling me the racist meet a sexist one.
But the bright side to that are the,
the people who came to me and said,
thank you for writing that like this had a really big impact on me.
I've shared it with my coworkers and I were talking about these things in the
office.
And so even though like thousands of people hated me,
like there were,
there were some who actually,
you know,
got something out of it and at the end of the day that makes it all worth it.
Good.
So I'm going to let you ask the last question.
You are the three people are just being discriminated against.
I'm sorry.
Um,
and,
and then I'm going to ask that we give our final remarks probably starting with
you David,
and then coming this way.
Um,
partially answering her question and partially probably ignoring it and saying
whatever you're going to say.
Anyway,
so go ahead.
So I'll do this quick.
The love army makes sense,
right?
It's something we can all do.
We can all fight for and embrace others.
But how do we fight a two pronged fight when one,
it's in Washington and as you brought up,
they don't,
they block everything.
We're,
we're fighting this fight against people who don't respect the rules of
engagement in which we are playing with him and here at Google and throw out the
tech industry.
They don't respect science as much.
We see this kind of anti elitism,
they don't respect the science or the data or they think that we are doing
something negative or influencing in a negative way.
So how do we both have a love army but also fight a fight in which the rules of
engagement on both tech and,
and DC are not?
There was an engagement that we've been playing with for the past eight years,
at least.
Good.
So let me kind of take that,
which is,
it's a tough question.
Um,
and uh,
add a little bit to it so people can answer it as,
as they will.
Um,
we do have this challenge of we want to stand up for our values and we also want
to be inclusive.
Um,
and that's true.
Whether it has to do with Trump,
whether it has to do with race,
whether it has to do with gender,
sexuality,
this is a tough thing.
Um,
and,
um,
as we think about,
uh,
giving folks here some guidance going forward,
what,
what thoughts might you leave people with in light of that challenge?
Um,
Mr Devin,
I don't know if I'm the right one.
Then why don't you take it?
Why don't you take it,
Nancy?
I the question.
Look at w w we have to do two things that are hard.
We have to stick up for our values and we have to reach out.
Yeah.
Um,
how do you do that and how do you think about that?
And if you don't want to answer it,
say I don't care.
I'm going to say what I want to say cause I only got one,
one last comment we got.
Yeah.
I mean from a personal standpoint because I,
it's,
it's really tough.
I joked with a lot of people that I feel like I am eight jobs because I really
just want to focus on my skills and talents,
but I know I can't write.
I know that to just say that I'm good at this without dealing with the fact that
there's all the surrounding stuff that's blocking me from trying to survive in
this space.
It's important to me to make it better for someone else.
It'd be great if everybody did their part to help with that.
But I mean like for personally it's,
it definitely feels like a burden that I've taken on and I constantly am
thinking about it from like a self care perspective.
Like how much should I take on?
And sometimes I really wish I didn't have to.
That's my truth.
David.
Yeah,
I would just say so I think there still needs to be a period of militancy on
values.
Uh,
in addition to the outreach,
the,
I'm very worried as I,
I my comment earlier about unilateral disarmament,
but I feel like there's a little bit of a,
a symmetrical kind of battle going on where you have these values and you,
you think that there's,
you know,
truth and like things that you can actually verify in the world that are true
and that makes sense.
Or the things that are,
you know,
that our principal a and you want to stick to them and you've got folks on the
other side of the debate sort of,
you know,
disregarding all of that stuff,
right.
And it gives them a leg up and a lot of ways because the,
you know,
they figured out how to master media and they realized that the 24 new hour news
cycle or the two hour new cycle or whatever it is,
people forget when you say something that's wrong,
they just come away thinking,
oh,
they scored a good point.
So I feel,
you know,
Yo,
that ultimately should collapse,
right.
Because at some point,
you know,
disinformation,
maybe you can only sustain that.
I think for so long,
at least I'm hopeful of that and I,
I think that continued militancy in the face of that,
calling it out,
you know,
making sure that your volume values are front and center and so forth still
needs to happen before we go.
You know,
we sort of let everything down and sort of normalize every viewpoint as,
you know,
can't we just get along?
Right,
right.
Uh,
so that,
that would be my response.
Yeah.
Very good.
And you just want to add on that,
um,
you are still at Google,
one of the most wealthy,
powerful institutions that's ever existed in the history of the world and a lot
more people love searching on Google and using their android phone and watching
a youtube video and checking their g mail than voted for Donald Trump.
You have a lot of power and you don't have to apologize for using it.
You don't have to be,
you know,
halfassed about using it.
Uh,
I think,
you know,
you have buy in from senior level and talk about being militant,
right?
That is incredibly,
incredibly,
you said it,
I heard it.
I'm going to tweet it later.
That'll make it true.
But,
but I mean it in,
in all seriousness like there,
there,
there's no excuse for not using it.
And I,
and I don't say that lightly because I think there's great responsibility with
great power,
but if you all don't step up,
then who can,
it's not the people who lost their factory jobs.
It is not all these other people.
But this is,
this is the place that has the power and the influence and the daily connection
with billions of people to be able to do it.
And I think you can do it in ways that are thoughtful.
I'm fine if you want to express that is how you compete in the market.
If you want to say we're better than Microsoft and Amazon,
then the Facebook
on this feature because we built it to be more empathetic and thoughtful because
we baked our values into it.
I would love to have that beat.
The criteria by which I choose a product.
That's great.
Thank you.
Um,
yeah,
you,
you and me.
Okay.
Um,
similar to what Nancy was saying earlier,
I think it's,
it's really important to,
you know,
just stand up and support your,
your coworkers.
You're a diverse coworkers and advocate for them.
And you know,
if you're in a meeting with one of them and they,
they have an idea that you like say,
Oh yeah,
like that was a really great idea.
It's just really little things like that can actually,
they can go a long way.
So just,
yeah,
just try to keep supporting everyone and keep that in mind.
Thank you.
Can you,
uh,
like Nancy,
I was really nervous about coming up here is the token white,
middle aged Jewish guy,
you know,
representing,
uh,
and uh,
you were all so inclusive and gracious like way too much in fact.
Cause basically all I did was show up.
But I do love the idea of bring,
bring someone who needs to be here that uh,
isn't inclined to come.
And I think that's a great way just to catch the infectious positive energy that
I'm feeling in this room.
Very good.
Well look,
I want to thank everybody here.
Um,
you know,
when we talk about love and we talk about melting,
see those things go together very well.
Honestly,
like a mama bear is militant about her love for her cubs.
Let love is not weak.
Love is the opposite of weak.
Um,
and,
and I think it's about loving harder.
I'm concerned about the people who Trump is targeting Muslims.
Everybody.
I'm also concerned,
I mean,
just took a long list,
a long list,
but I also want to say this,
this is the challenge.
I'm also concerned with the people that he's tricking.
When he tells coal miners he's going to frack everywhere and give them their
jobs back in the coal mines,
he's tricking them.
If you frack everywhere,
you collapse the price of natural gas,
you put every coal miner out of work.
That's my problem too.
I'm PR underdogs and red states and blue states,
and I think that that's the winning formula.
And so I want to be militant about the love that I feel for the dreamers and the
native Americans who are out there fighting for the pipeline.
And those call guys were being tricked,
and if were that way,
we're going to win.
So I'll thank you very much.